[Music]
dc fandom finally gave us our first real
look at a certain superhero who's
calling himself vengeance
in the first official trailer from matt
reeves is to batman bruce wayne
ominously refers to himself simply as
vengeance
and frankly the scene in which robert
pattinson utters that line and the
teaser is so badass
we'd be happy to call bruce wayne's
masked alter ego that name for all
eternity
the hell are you supposed to be
i'm vengeance the footage also offered
up glimpses at some of the people who
will be working with
and or against batman depicted in his
early 30s and clearly struggling with
more than just his status as a city
protecting vigilante
while fans were no doubt elated to get a
look at jeffrey wright as gotham city
police department commissioner james
gordon
zoe kravitz is catwoman and paul dano is
the riddler shown throughout the trailer
with his face obscured by a mask and
goggles
it's the appearance of a certain other
iconic batman villain that has everyone
talking
that villain is oswald oz cobblepot
who's destined to become the nefarious
penguin from batman lore
in the new film colin farrell portrays
pre-penguin cobblepot and in order to
bring the well-known batman baddie to
life
beryl apparently had to undergo an
intense transformation
the batman trailer shows who everyone is
claiming is feral azaz cobblepot
looking categorically unrecognizable
behind a truckload of prosthetics and
sporting a balding wig
it looks so unlike his regular self that
many fans didn't realize it was actually
feral they were seen in the batman's
teaser
and others are still in disbelief that
it's truly feral
filmmaker ben meckler quickly took to
twitter upon hearing the digital buzz
about farrell and the penguin and the
batman
in an effort to clear up the confusion
meckler tweeted that he reached out to
his pal and the batman screenplay
co-writer matson tomlin to get
confirmation that the man seen in the
batman trailer is 100
feral meckler wrote immediately texted
matson tomlin to make sure cause i
couldn't believe it
it's him all right as it is farrell's
prosthetic heavy appearance in the
batman trailer means the character may
be far more of an unknown quantity than
expected that's likely a good thing as
the footage for the batman paints reeves
new batflick as more of a grounded
noir-tinged tale of hero vs villains
meaning a more comic faithful adaptation
of the penguin would feel extremely out
of place
in a recent interview with gma news
farrell also teased we'll be seeing less
of his character in the villain pack the
batman than previously thought
he shared i haven't got that much to do
i'm not all over it by any means
it seems that farrell's two blink and
you miss him scenes in the batman's
teaser trailer may represent the bulk of
his screen time for the film
happily though the actor went on to note
he still got a few choice moments with
mr vengeance in the batman
he dished there are a couple of some
tasty scenes i haven't into my creation
and i can't wait to get back
it feels original and fun but i'm only
at the start of the journey so i can't
wait to get back and really get into it
that start of the journey tease may not
sound like much but with barrel
apparently
playing second fiddle to the riddler and
the batman it could mean his penguin is
setting up to feature predominantly in a
batman sequel
the batman is set for release on october
1st 2021
the film also stars andy circus as
alfred pennyworth the wayne family's
faithful butler and bruce's most trusted
confidant
john turturro is mob boss and batman
enemy carmine palcone
peter skarsgard as district attorney gil
coulson and jamie lawson as mayoral
candidate bella real
as well as charlie carver max carver and
gil perez abraham in undisclosed roles
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]